son dos las unidades que reivindicaron
la incursión armada en la región rusa de
belgorón una a la legión libertad de
Rusia incluye a militares desertores y
la otra es el cuerpo de voluntarios
rusos de extrema derecha fundado por
Denis niquin un neonazi que ha vivido en
Alemania ambos están comprometidos con
el derrocamiento del gobierno de
Vladimir Putin kiev declaró que no
estaba implicada en el ataque de
belgorón pero expertos en seguridad
creen que las autoridades ucranianas
tienen vínculos con estos grupos
Insurgentes tenemos que darnos cuenta de
que no se trata de fuerzas
independientes Aunque la reivindicación
sea la de seguir diciendo que esto no
tiene nada que ver con nosotros que se
trata solo de voluntarios rusos están
controlados por la inteligencia militar
ucraniana imágenes de la televisión
Estatal rusa mostraron vehículos
militares de fabricación estadounidense
supuestamente distribuidos durante la
incursión pero Estados Unidos se mostró
evasivo las preguntas sobre la
implicación de material militar
estadounidense
diré que en este momento somos
escépticos sobre la veracidad de estos
informes como principio general como
hemos dicho y creo que dije ayer no
alentamos ni permitimos ataques dentro
de Rusia y lo hemos dejado Claro
pero como también hemos dicho
corresponde a Ucrania decidir Cómo
llevar a cabo esta guerra Durante los 15
meses de guerra ya ha habido incursiones
de drones en territorios rusos pero
nunca a tal escala esto abre la
posibilidad de que Moscú tenga que
luchar en un segundo frente antes de la
contraofensiva de Ucrania esperada desde
hace tiempo